today we're going to talk about  lgbtq plus issues that's right no God  no God please no okay I've made a huge  mistake this  there is no way that that this woman is  going to take this anywhere funny  I tweeted out female colored bisexual  throughout my life these have proven to  be obstacles from time to time but now  I'm fully embracing them as my  superpowers no matter how many boxes you  check I encourage you to do the same and  I really do  okay they're applauding her tweet that's  what's we've been reduced to and no  being bisexual is not a superpower  what's your superpower oh I Can Fly And  you what's your superpower I can like  ride dolphins and and I have a magical  Trident and you what's yours I can have  sex with different people so no not a  superpower also not funny